everyone's done something embarrassing
but most people don't have their biggest
mistakes seen by millions of people
these movie flops hit their actors a
little too hard the disappointing box
office for Shazam Fury of the guards was
not a surprise by the time the long
delayed superhero sequel hit theaters in
March 2023 a full reboot of the DC
Universe had already been announced
making the film already seem like
yesterday's news and getting worse
reviews in the 2019 original didn't help
matters while the fate of Shazam and
James Gunn's new DC Universe has yet to
be officially decided star Zachary Levi
has certainly been acting like his one
steady superhero gig is threatened if
not already over on his Instagram
account Levi pleaded for moviegoers to
boost the Rotten Tomatoes audience score
for Fury of the Gods to increase the
discrepancy with the negative critic
score saying because it doesn't make any
sense it doesn't make any sense that we
got shook down the way that we got shut
down it really doesn't while begging
more people to see his current movie
He's also been publicly asking for new
role he tweeted at Neil druckman asking
to join the cast of The Last of Us Levi
has also provided a look at some of the
chaos behind the scenes at Warner
Brothers specifically calling out Dwayne
Johnson for blocking the Justice Society
of America characters from the Black
Adam movie from cameoing and fury of the
Gods and avito Inga potential Shazam
cameo in Black Adam
in general it's easier to find more
examples of writers and directors
feeling devastated following a flop than
actors it makes sense why audiences
rejecting a film can feel more personal
when it's a product of your vision such
as a case with Bros the well-received
but financially unsuccessful 2022 gay
rom-com that Billy Eichner starred in
co-wrote and executive produced in a
sense the leader tweet Eichner said even
with glowing reviews great Rotten Tomato
scores an a cinema score
Etc straight people especially in
certain parts of the country just didn't
show up for Bros this assessment of why
the movie flopped was naturally subject
to controversy homophobia was likely one
factor for why the film sold as the
first major Studio Movie with an
all-lgbtq lead cast struggled in
theaters but the fact is a lot of lgbtq
viewers avoided the movie as well
judging by the box office results
perhaps this was due to poor marketing
or maybe people just felt like this type
of movie is something they'd rather
watch on streaming than theaters before
I became a household name chunk black
was half of the comedy Rock band's
Tenacious D alongside Kyle Gas the D had
an HBO series in the late 90s and thanks
in parts of Black's breakout performance
and High Fidelity the band's got a
record contract and released their
self-titled first album in 2001. in 2006
they're long in the works movie
Tenacious D in The Pick of Destiny
finally hit theaters but nobody saw it
directed by Liam Lynch and co-written by
Lynch black and gas this fantasy origin
story about the band's formation and
quest to claim Satan's guitar pick got
mixed reviews from critics who
questioned whether the band's Stoner
stick that worked great in episodic
format successfully sustained a full
feature black described the film's box
office failure as a huge loss to Maxim
magazine and quit screenwriting as a
result tenacious D's next album 2012's
rise of the Phoenix opened with the
lines when The Pick of Destiny was
released it was a bomb they joked about
the experience with a fictional story of
the group breaking up and needing to
read unite as a result of that failure
though he was heartbroken by this
financial failure black has been
heartened by the fact that his fans
still enjoy the movie years later
2003 was not a great year for Ben
Affleck his growing celebrity was met
with a growing backlash and his acting
credits that year was Savaged by critics
one of those was Gili the ROM common
which Affleck played a gangster with a
silly sounding name who falls in love
with a lesbian played by Jennifer Lopez
became one of the most infamous bombs of
the 21st century the fact Affleck began
dating Lopez on the set of the film made
for perfect tabloid fodder cementing its
infamy even when Aflac has starred in
bigger money losers reflecting on G Lee
20 years later in an interview at The
Hollywood Reporter afflux said there's
still some good stuff in the film while
admitting that overall it didn't work
but that's what really hurt was how the
response to the film impacted people's
perceptions of him as a person I can see
now how people looked at me and thought
of this person as some callow frat guy
who's Cavalier or has too much it
engendered a lot of negative feelings
and people about me there's that aspect
of people that I got to see that was sad
and hard it was depressing and really
made me question things and feel
disappointed and have a lot of
self-doubt else
no why
don't always can't be over the top
performance as a movie star and abusive
mother Joan Crawford in the 1981 drama
Mommy Dearest was instantly divisive she
was runner-up for best actress of the
National Society of film critics Awards
and the New York Film critics Circle
Awards and also won worst actress at the
razzies and the stinkers bad movie
awards though the movie has gone on to
be embraced as a so bad it's good cult
film it disappointed at the box office
and had a negative effect on dunaway's
Career the actor has mostly avoided
talking about her experience with Mommy
Dearest but in a 2016 interview with
people she explained that in the
aftermath of the film's release people
would irretrievably have the wrong
impression of me she considers the movie
a bad decision but one she can't take
back saying it's unfortunate they felt
they had to make that kind of movie but
you can't be ashamed of the work you've
done you make a decision and then you
have to live with the consequence
does any actor expressed their hatred
for a certain role of theirs and George
Clooney has with his performance as a
Dark Knight and Batman and Robin the
1997 Joel Schumacher flight was one of
the first movies to be majorly hit by
nerd backlash in the early years of the
internet killing the live-action Batman
movie franchise until Christopher
Nolan's reboot the failure didn't hurt
Clooney's career as he'd rise up as one
of the biggest stars in Hollywood in the
Years following its release but it's
nonetheless an experience he regrets one
article from vulture in 2014 chronicled
six different instances of Clooney
apologizing for or making fun of Batman
and Robin over the years and he's
continued to do it multiple times since
including on The Graham Norton Show in
2015. I always apologize
in particular he's complained about how
hard it was to act in the Batman suit
and just made plentiful jokes about that
version of the suit's infamous nipples
even when accepting icon of the year on
us from GQ in 2020 Clooney still made
sure to talk about how bad his acting
was in Batman and Robin in the context
of being honest about one's shortcomings
even Clooney's hatred of Batman and
Robin might not compare to the Shia
loathing Bob huskins felt towards a 1993
Super Mario Brothers movie long before
Chris Pratt voiced an animated Mario in
2023's the Super Mario Brothers movie
Hoskins wore the red plumber's uniform
in a bizarre live-action adaptation that
seemingly took more inspiration from
Blade Runner than from the Whimsical
Nintendo games Hoskins didn't even know
the movie was based on a video game when
he started working on it when his kids
told him he responded I used to play
King Leah the production was a mess
going over schedule and over budget with
the script constantly changing Hoskins
and his co-star John Leguizamo were
drinking a lot on set and once done
broke Hoskins finger or this suffering
from a movie that was universally hated
by critics and Mario fans alike in a
2011 interview with the guardian Hoskins
called Super Mario Brothers his worst
job biggest disappointment and the one
thing he wished he could have raised
from his past what could even be said
about Obama's bad and bafflingly
weirdest cats the stars of Tom Hooper's
2019 and Kenny Valley adaptation of
Andrew Lloyd Webber's hit musical have
mostly responded to the film's critical
and financial failure James Corden and
Rebel Wilson marked the special effects
of the Oscars Taylor Swift and Sir Ian
McKellen emphasized that they had fun on
the set of that ridiculous movie and
Dame Duty Dench didn't even see it some
actors have praised the film While
others criticized it but none of them
responded with anger or hatred towards
the film except Jason Derulo the rumchum
Tugger in cats was a singer's first
acting role which might explain why he
felt more defensive about it than his
co-stars speaking to TMZ at the time of
the film's release he questioned whether
critics knew what they were even talking
about asking now they made a film ever
in their life he later told the
telegraph I thought it was going to
change the world ultimately he says he
learned a lesson from The Experience
saying you can't wait for the perfect
moment because that might not be your
moment so you've just got to go for gold
that's how I'll move forward Neo
Marshall's 2019 reboot of Hellboy
starring David Harbor is a titular Red
Demon was greeted with skepticism from
the moment it was announced many fans
were disappointed that Guillermo del
Toro never got the chance to make a
third Hellboy film with Ron Pullman and
harbor believes that this disappointment
colored the reactions to the reboot
leading critics and fans to judge it and
fairly speaking with a digital spy
shortly after the film's release Harper
admitted that the film had big problems
but that it was still unfairly
criticized based on audiences
expectations in 2022 he opened up to GQ
about having a hard time personally
following the film's failure and even
called Ryan Reynolds who had his own
widely hated superhero flop with Green
Lantern for support Harbor succinctly
put the ultimate lesson he learned from
his Hellboy experience this way I
learned not to
with an established IP that's for sure
the 2008 comedy The Love Guru is one of
those red bombs so disastrous and
basically single-handedly killed his
lead actors career Mike Meyer starred in
co-wrote and co-produced the film and he
won razzies for all three of those jobs
aside from voice acting in the fourth
Shrek film he hasn't had a leading role
in a movie since only occasionally
appearing on TV in documentaries and in
bit parts and films despite the huge
failure of The Love Guru and its
devastating impact on his career Maya
still defended the film in a 2014 GQ
interview saying there's a lot in that
movie comedically that I'm really really
proud of I completely recognize that
didn't meet an audience he also tries
not to get too personally upset about
the film bombing saying I just love
making stuff dude you know you can't be
too attached up and you can't be too a
touchdown unlike the other examples on
this list Jennifer Lawrence was not
personally bothered by the fact that
2017 psychological horror movie mother
bombed the ultraviolent religious
allegory he was always going to confuse
some viewers and defend others so it's
not a shocker that critics were divided
on the film and mainstream audiences
rejected it in their variety actors on
actors video discussion with Adam
Sandler Lawrence said she typically
doesn't read reviews or think about her
films after she's done promoting them so
why is Lawrence on this list because
that's revealed in the variety video the
film's writer director and her
then-boyfriend Darren Aronofsky was
devastated by the response to the film
and Lawrence got sick of him constantly
talking about the film's reviews I was
doing double duty of you know trying to
be a supportive partner while also being
like can I please for the love of God
not think about mother for one second
Lawrence describes the dynamic as
unhealthy for both of them and she broke
up with Aronofsky in the months after
the film's release
foreign
[Music]